well just like uber did to the car
industry just like airnb Airbnb did to
the hotel industry just like Bitcoin did
to just normal Financial products and
fungible tokens and all that fun stuff
just like podcast did to Media same
thing's going on here with commercial
real estate Tom hit the nail on the head
damn right did you know it but I hit it
we supply and demand we've got too much
office space and not enough homes so
what do we mean we all see what happened
during Co we started using using
acronyms like w fa work from anywhere
wfh work from home Co basically was the
Catalyst to what was already going to
happen people were already working
remote these things were already
occurring and then boom covid Zoom
meetings just smack you right in the
face next thing you know you're working
you got your you know your mullet outfit
going on you got you know business up
top Party Down Below you're in your
boxer briefs downstairs